Eric can you tell us about the first
screenplay you sold what was happening
in your life at that moment in time and
how many had you written previously wow
that takes me back I was still at UCLA
as a grad student and I was in work in
my first year working on my PhD I mean I
always knew I wanted to teach at the
college level sometimes so I wanted to
get those required degrees in early and
I just love college and I wouldn't let
anybody tear me out of there
so I was still working on the PhD but
there was another student there doctoral
student there whose stepfather was a
director and he asked do you have
anything do you have any stories and I
was working on something I was a head of
Novell I was working on at the time it
was kind of for the time kind of an
uppity romantic comedy so I gave it to
de David E Miller was the director if
anybody wants to look that one up in
film history he was a great studio a
mainstream studio director and did some
really good work but David really liked
it and he wanted to option it and work
on it with me and I said that sounds
pretty good and I was what 20 23 24 I
think I was 24 at the time and that's
what that's why I never went back for
the second year and and Beyond and I
never did my dissertation for the for
the doctoral degree because I wasn't
bought out of there and paid to write a
screenplay and I was 24 and maybe a
little more cocky than I should have
been I figured I got this knocked you
know I'm I'm I'm off and running and
well the first life lesson it was to be
another eight years before I got my next
assignment my second assignment
but I was doing PhD in theater so I had
been writing stage plays for a number of
years but that's what it was it was
called the menopause of Henrietta luck
and it was I was a romantic comedy what
sparked the idea for the novella good
question where do these I don't know I
don't know I'm not sure I could tell you
it was it was a woman a rather reserved
woman in her late 30s was that was the
the main character the heroine and she
had a father who was crotchety and
uppity and mentally not quite all there
and I just kind of came I think from
family history we have a lot of
eccentrics in our family so you know I
was working the old your own family sort
of material so then what did your own
family think of you leaving this ph.d
program right at UCLA to quote-unquote
go to Hollywood I mean you're still in
LA but you're you're crossing the line
into town another part of town and then
become an adult and not as a perpetual
student mm-hmm it was fine what's hot
you know I said I was I'm a very lucky
person when it comes to prayer to
parents really truly I mean we were what
would you call it middle class lower
middle class basically as a family
but I had to loving caring wonderful
people for prayer for parents and I
learned to value that more and more as
life goes on
truly truly that was a blessing and my
dad was the scientist and my mom was not
an artist in and of herself but she's
the one who understood it you know go do
what you're good at
so no no they understood and the plan
was always that I would go back
well one thing led to another and I
never did go back to the ph.d program so
that you had their blessing you you sell
this script is that right yes it made no
no it's not me hating okay and what are
you doing in that eight years
what's your progression of mood output
during that eight years
well after that basically up to that
point I had never even been in a room
with a motion picture camera in the same
room so my girlfriend at the time Diane
she had applied and gotten into the
American Film Institute and I said oh I
sounds pretty good and that's better
than going out into the world and going
to work so I applied to and we both got
in the American Film Institute and we
both already had a master fine arts
terminal degree in theater from UCLA and
then we went into the master Fine Arts
program at the AFI myself as a
screenwriter and Diane is a director
she's a wonderful director and so we got
to hide out for another three years but
after that then I focused on writing and
so did you think that it would just be a
matter of a few years until you churn
out the next script and sell it again
and you could sort of capture lightning
in a bottle again
I wasn't that optimistic optimistic yes
you have to be to a certain extent but
I'm also a realist I just knew I had to
do it and it was another speaking of
luck
Diane was another major major part of my
luck because this lady took a chance you
know that very very few young beautiful
women I think would be willing to take
on a guy from nowhere who said he was
going to be a writer fat chance right
you know put all her marbles on that and
she did and I just
it was an amazing journey and that she
took that chance was something and I
just kept working and I started to get
work okay if you're a writer in any form
in any genre if you're a writer you're
going to get kicked in the teeth
I mean that's that goes with that goes
with the territory it's just that's the
way it happens so you got to get used to
certain things you have to find that
self that peace within yourself and
toughen your skin get alligator hide
because it's coming and it is going to
come and then you just try every the
best way possible that you know how to
do to learn from it all learn from it
all and I was not my now I was pretty
shy kid basically is what it comes down
to I was not a tremendously outgoing
person at that time I didn't hadn't
mastered mastered that skill yet but I
felt I had a plan I knew I couldn't do
it by bashing on bashing on doors
kicking doors down pounding on tables
like you to exaggerate to make a point I
wasn't one of those people but what I
could do is make myself
inevitable by continuing to crank out
original material and that is exactly
what happened I just kept writing and I
just kept rewriting and rewriting until
they were pretty darn good
so when opportunities came as eventually
they did I was ready I had scripts
different genres you know what do you
want what do you want to see and
ultimately I ended up with a top well
I'm not gonna bandy names about at this
point but a top agent literary agent in
Hollywood which kind of changed
everything and you know made other
things possible and it was just because
I had a drawer full of scripts but I
would I would like to say this before we
move on I've written 17 feature
screenplays
for remuneration you know on assignment
shall we say of those seventeen six got
made of those six I get screen credit on
five of the five I get shared screen
credit on three and sole screen credit
on two and the reason I like to run that
down for people is that is a pretty
typical career career arc for a working
screenwriter it's not what a lot of
people coming into the field think it's
going to be no basically you end up
making your living and it can be at
times a very good living off of stuff
that is never going to get made because
whether it's made or not those are
financial decisions those are business
decisions and your original material you
crank out can be very very good and be a
good work sample but I have a number of
scripts that were never made never never
optioned yes but never made because they
were wrong in their timing for the
business at that at that moment so
that's truly I think kind of a glimpse
of the true nature of this business I
don't think it's changed too much since
then people need to know that who are
genuinely interested in and fantasize or
see the possibility of them becoming
screenwriters they need to buckle down
for the long haul because that's what it
is
and then the notoriety you said that
even though these were your works you
you know these were your scripts but
your name was either taken out or and
and knowing that that's part of you know
that you're not going to be blasted all
over the trades yeah and being okay with
that yeah that's that's a part of the
life yeah yes as a working screenwriter
this is this is the thing people who
want to pursue this
and I definitely understand it because
it I got the bug early and I want I mean
no I knew I was a writer in the fourth
grade and I say you know it didn't I
didn't choose it it choose it chose me
and okay so that fate question is
decided and we move forward and see
where it takes you but every writer who
does not come from money who does not
come from great resources as most of us
do not there are two tracks to your life
and the woman the first is doing
everything you can with who you are and
your personality toward fulfilling that
the desire then the creative need to do
these things and write these scripts and
maybe some of them will get made and
that's a separate discussion maybe like
them but also the second track being you
have to find a way you have to build for
yourself because nobody else is gonna do
it for you an ongoing source of life
sustenance separate from your creative
career you have to build the I think
build that into your plan from the
beginning because even when you do get
start getting hunks of money it comes in
hunks and at times it can be wonderful
that can be very big hunks but when that
happens you have to really know how to
how to turn that money into income in
indefinite income I mean I have so many
friends of course it's so hard and you
struggle and all of a sudden you're
making the big bucks and and your name
is in variety it for a few times and all
that and so they run and says you know I
work so hard I really deserve this and
they go up and buy the big house on the
hill which is certainly understandable
and five or six years lady you know
they're selling it they're desperate and
selling it and they lose it because
every year is not like that it doesn't
always rain gold coins in this business
it's going to be very sporadic take what
you make turn it into income
and that's what I did what we did I
advised income real estate but something
so that you can have a life separate and
and assured I made it depends I mean
Diana and I we wanted kids we had I mean
when we had kids pretty pretty soon
pretty early on and the responsibilities
mountains you know and you got to do
both you got to do both and it can be
done that way Araki you were director of
a top university Masters of Fine Arts
screenwriting program can we talk about
how did you become qualified for the
position what's your background
what would your daily activities well as
as we were talking about earlier I had a
background rather extensive background
in surviving at least surviving for 23
years as a screenwriters and
occasionally TV writer as well and so
they came to me with this offer of the
possibility of tenure-track teaching
screenwriting I mean this was 18 years
ago so this was at a time when
screenwriting at the university level
was becoming more and more in demand
more and more important all the major
universities you know one by one we're
creating these departments in these
courses specifically in grad programs
for the MFA which is the terminal degree
but you need to teach it and so forth
and I suffered over the decision because
I was you know making a living and so
forth but I decided to go ahead and
because I'd always wanted to go back to
a khadeem and I loved it and I loved the
the Edit of this the atmosphere of it
and the working with people a writer
spends 90% of their working life you
understand in a room alone it's not
always good for the head and the
emotional structure within but that's
just you know part of the job so you
kind of find other ways it getting out
there and this seemed like a good one
and in the beginning I thought I've made
a horrible mistake because it's a
bureaucracy it is you know it's
something that I was not familiar with
in terms of participating in and all
that but as time went on very quickly I
met wonderful people in the faculty and
the tenure track the tenure track
climbed to a full professor is not an
easy one I don't know people realize
that stuff people throw you know they
say I'm professor of this and that there
are very few of those around it is a it
is a process that can test and try ones
in Duras endurance and and and other
abilities intellectual capabilities and
all this other stuff but one of the main
reasons I did it was because I wanted to
write a book about screenwriting
and I knew if I took the professorship I
would have to because that would be part
of the package deal in order to get to
full professor right so what I found was
what I didn't expect which was a career
that is in many many ways so much more
fulfilling than being a screenwriter her
screenwriter alone and we started
working together and I mean not just me
but there are a number of very good
people in this department that wanted
this MFA and screenwriting program to to
be born and to flourish and we worked on
it and over the years it grew and into
something that were all well yes I'll
admit it were proud of it just in the
last year and a half by the way relative
to the program again forgive me for this
but let's see it was it was first
Hollywood Reporter included us as one of
the top 25 film schools in America and
and then shortly after that Daily
Variety put us in the top 40 film
schools in the world
Wow and it was a lot of work but we were
really pleased with the result how far
we've come so it was a chance at a total
second career and a very
one in its own way and and fulfilling
fulfilling and rewarding so within those
18 years how have you seen the way
students approach screenwriting or their
view of it change and I know we're in
Los Angeles so it's totally skewed I'm
sure it's the same in New York but do
you think first of all in other parts of
the country this would be as successful
this program I don't I don't know and
I'm I don't know but my guess is and my
best guess is that I it depends on the
people running the department and the
program and how often they can get there
grad students out to LA but I don't know
I would guess it would be harder to be
successful out beyond a certain radius
beyond Los Angeles because this is it
this is the movie TV making center of
the universe so to speak is right here
and one of the things we can do is the
people we bring in to teach I mean me
for instance but even the part-timers
and the lecturers and so forth these are
working people in the industry on a
regular basis they know they know the
truth and when you find one of those who
is also a really good teacher and that's
interestingly that's kind of like two
separate skills but when you get that
combo you've got a really great great
faculty and you know you can you can oh
and also in in LA what's we require this
we I don't know how many MFA programs in
screenwriting have this I know a number
of them do but I don't know if it's
limited or not we have an internship
program that is required in the last
semester so we send our people out to we
work we have we have a great
relationship with a great number of
production companies and development
companies of material where our grads in
screenwriting go out and intern
and it connects them with the business
and this is important and it helps make
it a stronger program it really does and
a lot of our people you know one of the
things you can possibly learn when you
come to an MFA screenwriting program may
be that long term as a career
screenwriting or television writing
alone for you may not be the right way
to go for any individual but there is so
much to be learned in the program so
many tools to be acquired and mastered
when they go out in their internships
and meet the people doing this and
producing this and the creative
directors of companies and stuff like
that one of the first things that
happens when anybody gets hired I mean
in any level in in Hollywood it's an
agency it's it's a production company
usually in the first week or two
somebody drops by you're juggling the
coffee or whatever it is if your task is
and they drop a script in front of you
and they say you know I've read this
over the weekend we tell me what you
think of it on Monday and it's all very
casual and low-key but the truth is this
is one of the most important moments of
your professional life because how you
respond to reading that script and how
you speak of it afterwards will tell
them a great deal about how useful or
not you will be to a company going
forward that is in the creative business
and our people do that very very well
and so a number of I mean they can take
a script by the time they finish here we
we beaten it into them and they can take
a screenplay and they'll tell you
exactly what's right with it what's
wrong with it and precisely how to fix
it yeah its strengths its weaknesses
what it needs to be changed
and and they do that well out there in
their internships and now we have a half
a dozen or so bar var people climbing
the the kind of the more business and
creative business and of the latter and
doing very very well out there are you
able to talk about some of the scripts
that you go through as examples for part
of the curriculum are you some certain
movies that you tend to focus on or
directors sure sure
I use I use a lot of scripts because I'm
encouraging people to read I'm forcing
them to read as a matter of fact it's
hard these days by the way I must say
even though I'm Generation X I'm seeing
myself being you know torn away from
reading more and more how is that in
this digital age where you know 140
characters is considered reading yes
it's problematic
it's very problematic but you're getting
people used to the idea
just great yes and I'm with a great a
sense of personal urgency also if I may
throw a statistic at you in 1946 just
after World War Two at a time when only
about 10% of the population nation's
population went to college or could
afford to go to college the GI Bill
hadn't kicked in yet you know it started
to change us but in 1946 the America the
general American population had a
reading vocabulary of 25,000 words
that's not recognition that is used in
you know in everyday conversation a
reading vocabulary 25,000 words by 1990
the average American had a reading vocab
speaking excuse me speaking vocabulary
of 10,000 words and since then I am sure
it has declined precipitously since then
that is what happened you read less you
just see images you live through images
you you know you use emojis to express
emotion and you don't need words you
don't have the subtlety of words or the
variety
vocabulary and it limits I believe truly
limits how people can think even
intelligent people how completely they
can think and that's why reading actual
words on actual paper is incredibly
important for young writers and so
you're encouraging them to read novels
as well or mostly just in the screenplay
format well I would say I would hope I
would hope novels as well I mean that's
one of the things I say look guys if you
were setting out to become a novelist
couldn't we take it for granted that in
your life you had read thousands perhaps
multiple thousands of novels before you
actually sit down to write one what
should the difference be if you say you
want to be a screenwriter can't we
assume that you have written hundreds
upon written read hundreds of hundred on
hundreds of screenplays it seems to me
we can and then we do the hand thing you
know how many of you have read five
screenplays how many of ten it tapers
off at about twenty twenty-five you know
there's no more hands going up and then
I slay up the task you must be reading
constantly you you cannot write what you
do not read you just cannot and so
that's one of the things one of the
hurdles we have to face and draw them
into I mean they see if there's these
are smart people and they recognize it
bless their hearts but that's one of the
avenues where we have to travel now yes
I would encourage them also to be
writing novels I mean to be reading
novels because I think ultimately they
should also be writing novels but that's
a separate discussion but to to they
don't have enough time they're reading
all the other stuff for here and books
about screenwriting and filmmaking and
and then of course all the all the
screenplays Erin Brockovich is one of my
favorites Susannah grant screenplay for
Erin Brockovich I think that's one of
the better screenplays I've ever read
certainly in there you know with the
group there's so much to be learned in
that screenplay we were recently in one
of the classes they had have done that
and we spend an evening talking about it
the things that Susannah Graham does to
make it work to give it a style a
narrative style as well as just
exposition as as it goes forward stuff
like that how she creates characters
that live and each one with their own
voice there's a lot to learn there a lot
but of course it's not the only one we
have bunch of scripts yeah but Erin
Brockovich just one of your favorite do
you think it's because there's also she
was a real person it's it's there it's
she's still around she's still doing her
thing and that's very active that's
right see her on Twitter and yeah do you
think that that helps because it's a
it's a real person that they're basing
this story off of versus oh oh yeah yeah
most definitely in terms of you know
that single issue of character
absolutely the reason they made the
movie was because of the character and
what the character did but Susannah
grant as a screenwriter was in a
difficult position there because I'm I'm
guessing I do not know for certain but I
am guessing that from the beginning when
they got the right Taryn Brockovich is
story Miz Brockovich had in there some
sort of control over who the
screenwriter was going to be frequently
that's the way it's done so she
interviewed people and they kind of
clicked with she's clicked with Susannah
grant and Senator grants probably spent
a lot of time with her getting to know
her hearing is hearing her speech
patterns
hearing her use of vocabulary and an
emotional tempos and rhythms and stuff
like that and so yes I would say
absolutely it was a powerful influence
but that's only where it began you know
it's Susannah Grant who picked the
scenes and the ordering of the scenes
it's Susannah grant who
the story forward had her character the
main character driving the story forward
every step of the way what she did with
that was masterful and there's something
else about that one too
love to burn loved to burn up film here
tape there is a major problem in the
third act I mean this is getting pretty
esoteric but there's no there's a major
problem in the third act of of Erin
Brockovich which there is a point a
dramaturgical point that must happen
must happen ends in films that are going
to connect with large audiences and
because of the circumstances this is a
Erin Brockovich is a courtroom drama
really it's about somebody suing
somebody so the big payoff moment what's
called the obligatory scene would happen
which should happen in a courtroom but
Erin Brockovich is not an attorney so if
it happened in a courtroom the entire
big moment would take place with Erin
Brockovich just sitting there silently
watching and Susannah grant recognized
this quite correctly so that this was a
dramatic big dramatic problem so like a
really good screenwriter does she found
a way around that that gave it the
emotional punch kept the focus on Erin
and gave it the the sense of victory and
emotion for the audience at the ending
instead of the courtroom we'd never go
to the courtroom do you remember
yeah I'm remembering certain scenes
right now definitely yeah yeah accord
the end she was running around getting
everybody to sign right up for it
because they had X percent 90 percent or
something like that as all the people in
the town and had they had to sign this
affidavit or something like that and she
comes back and there's these two uptown
uppity lawyers and there's this funny
scene where
she basically lays out that she saved
the day
you know she's found the The Smoking Gun
she's got got the evidence and and it's
turned into a moment of emotional
victory for the hero with a substitute
adversary it's not I mean they're not
the real adversary PG&E is the real
adversary right I know this is kind of a
subtle thing but it is a remarkable
piece of screenwriting to know that and
to write it in such a way that it works
plus she had been fighting that
stereotypical Uptown person throughout
her working with Albert Finney the looks
that she would get whether it was her
fault for the way she was dressed and
some of the comments but she was
fighting that same stereotype so it was
like a culmination of that at that
moment yeah they are a brilliant writers
substitute for to provide the emotion
that cannot endure these circumstances
because it's a courtroom drama and she's
not a lawyer but that can provide the
substitution of an emotional payoff for
an audience and it works it works
how does Erin Brockovich grow how was
her character evolving and and changing
for the better in that film - trace -
trace character growth you have to the
writer doing it and anybody who wants to
understand it you know when it works
with other you know with other writers
doing it well in other films you have to
go back to certain basic questions and
the one in Erin Brockovich is what does
Erin want there is one thing and that's
what you have to get you know condense
it down - unless she wants this she
wants happy kids she wants money she
wants what does Erin inside what does
she want and need and you boil that down
that's question number one this is good
in general kind of stuff when you're
when you're when you're writing a
character a lead character heroine or or
hero right you've got to know certain
things about what makes them tick
I would offer that what Aaron Brock Erin
Brockovich wants is to be taken
seriously everything she does everything
she says everything she goes back to it
is about being taken seriously and but
then she finds out as she goes along and
her story she's getting closer and
closer to actually being taken seriously
it's costing her her family she's losing
her children and her children's
connection to her because she doesn't
have any time for them anymore remember
her son she's really getting kind of
twisted out of shape and you know he's
not happy with mom at all because she's
not around anymore
so the hero's journey emotionally the
inner journey it has to be it always has
to be hard that always has to be
difficult and you have to be able to
demonstrate it physically visibly to
demonstrate it and so you have to know
what they want and that has to come out
I mean really want their primary
defining want as a human being right and
you have to know their wound every
character that works and every character
who has character growth ultimately has
this deep inner wound it usually takes
place in the past before the film begins
but not always sometimes in in Finding
Nemo Merlin who is the hero of that
movie the wound happens right at the
beginning when he loses his wife and 999
out of his thousand eggs to this
Barracuda or whatever fish nasty fish
eats them all up and it's this is his
tragedy but the wound then defines that
character for the rest of the movie
until they are able to move beyond it
the wound the wound is
when a person has a wound going that
deep even you know in reality let alone
you know in fiction they tend to
insulate themselves and defend
themselves by creating this shield
between themselves in the world so
nothing that horrible or that painful
can ever happen to them again that's
usually when we meet them toward the
beginning of the story this person who
is isolated emotionally isolated behind
a shield and the journey toward
character growth is them figuring out
that they have to get away from the
shield they have to lay down the shield
and face the potential hurt and pain in
the world in order to connect with
humanity and and lead a full life you
know to connect with earth again can
people and and really live a complete
life rather than just be caged up and
you know and be gone and and never have
connected with anybody else and that is
what has happened to Erin she is behind
remember they have you have the scene
this is still in act one I think it is
and she's got the tiara and she's doing
her speech because she was Miss somebody
he's a Miss Wichita or something like
that right once I'm point and and she
said that I thought I was gonna be
somebody I thought I was gonna be able
to do something and then she found out
that she was just treated like a dumb
broad opening chain stores department
stores and they didn't expect anything
of her and they didn't want anything of
her they just wanted her to stand there
and look pretty and that was her wound
she she didn't see that I mean she
originally saw that as her opportunity
to to break free and you know be who she
knew she could be but didn't work so now
in her life while she's desperately
trying to put food on the table for her
kids she is also desperately seeking
away
to get people to take her seriously
and that's a wonderful place to start
character growth it really is and you
see the other co-workers and the
different people that she has to deal
with and probably one of the toughest
environments in terms of being accepted
in terms of she had lack you know no
education and sort of was seen again as
sort of a dumb whatever and and she's
coming against probably the worst
scrutiny and she feels it and she
strikes back and that's where we start
to see an interesting smart-mouth person
emerging yes exactly do you think a lot
of people related to her character ok
heck yes that was an international smash
you know yes and that's what I tell the
students - all the time my approach to -
screenwriting to teaching screenwriting
is mainstream commercial Hollywood
screenwriting that's what I'm going for
and that's I give them the tools for
that and there are many many tools
necessary really that most of the people
don't even realize exists when they
first come into the program but it
sounds like her story arc was relatable
yes yes is that is that not universal
right isn't is her circumstance not
universally relatable sure to women all
over the world and then it was a hit and
it was a hit and many many men and it
was a hit all over the world and that
that's as some of the students are a bit
cynical about my lack of cynicism about
Hollywood and movies that make a great
deal of money but I mean I just point
out that what money means is this film
touched untold millions of people where
they live it gave them a some form of a
rewarding emotional experience they got
what they came for a storytelling here
is an instance of storytelling
worked and that's what we need to learn
how to do because that's a language
that's a language and a craft and a
ritual that can be mastered many of the
students seen Erin Brokovich yes I make
them but most of them in its old enough
movie it was you know Asher yes
and so people let's say that are under
30 what's their reaction to the film
versus over 30 interesting interesting
because it seems like cynicism is in
these days oh it is it's it's it's you
know that's and it's an innocent it's
affecting the themes of contemporary
movies and spend hundreds of millions of
dollars making a movie whose theme is
life sucks and then you die mmm this is
a very disturbing time yes in Hollywood
it is in many many ways and that is
comes out of the cynicism of the young
and this is true I don't know I'd have a
hard time saying that they all read it
and see it and they they are they all
speak well of it it wasn't interesting
either just the other night we were
talking about this one of the students
said she really didn't like Erin
Brockovich not the movie the person I
don't like that character she's an awful
human being and I said well you know
characters he leads who work in movies
they can't be perfect because we don't
like perfect people huh we wanted to
know and love and care about flawed
people but and then you got a list got a
list the reasons we have been given that
the storyteller gave us to allow us to
identify with this hero the Erin
Brockovich and liked her anyway even for
her brashness and her outfits and her
outfits you taste you know no accounting
for Eric we're in this age of
everybody's trying to hack this and how
do we how do we do this faster so most
people
probably would turn to education as
another form of hacking how do we get
past a certain timeframe of putting
energy into something it's formal
education totally necessary when it
comes to writing can't someone still be
a brilliant screenwriter without having
to be part of an MFA program or even get
a bachelor's in writing the answer is
simple and the answer is absolutely yes
of course they can they can but mmm that
for most of us is choosing a very
difficult and lonely road and here is
why see this any art form before
anything can be art and appreciated as
something that has reached to the level
of art it is a craft first art is
created by craftspeople who have some
inspiration at one moment in their lives
or 50 moments in their lives when the
craft that they do so well rises to the
level of art but you cannot cut to art
without swimming through crafts without
creating an understanding the craft of
anything Georgiana Keefe I don't know
why she came to mind but then and Pablo
Picasso okay graphic artists who take it
to the level of true and pure art both
of them in their early years learned
their craft they learn perception they
learned color they're there you know
composition there are things you have to
learn tools that these artists have and
when they are mastered then they can
take it in to some very interesting
please and unexpected places but you've
still got the tools chess chess is a
rather interesting game and there are
untold millions of possibilities maybe
infinite possibilities there are six
pieces in a chess game but how to use
those
pieces and multiple combinations and so
I'd create probably the most fascinating
intricate and mind twisting game ever
invented
there are tools in screenwriting and I
would take the position that if this is
what somebody really wants if this is
what they're going for if this if all
their gifts lead them in this direction
then they need to get educated about the
tools you can do that on your own but it
you know but you'll need to read a lot
of books and sometimes I mean there's a
lot of great books on screen hiding out
of it you know don't get me wrong
there's a lot of great books and there
are tons and tons of garbage books on
screenwriting - and if you haven't got
you know some guidance you may be
wasting a lot of time on some of those
books but if you come to an MFA program
you are pursuing a couple of things
really you know what you what do you get
for your money in all guys death well
first of all you're going towards a
terminal degree a graduate terminal
degree that qualifies you to teach
tenure-track as a professor at the
college or and/or university level and
that's a major certificate that's a
major thing to have like me I had two of
them stashed away in the closet
somewhere when the opportunity came up
decades later okay
I'm qualified I'm prepared you know
let's go so that as a writer it gives
you another door to open another avenue
to pursue in life you are less hindered
remember I said you got to have two two
pathways to be pursued at the same time
your craft and art yes but at the same
time how to regularize an income well
you're a big step toward the second path
when you have an MFA just the
practicality of the degree but on the
other set a set of accomplishments it's
about the tools the tools you will learn
who that never you never knew existed
so many people who don't get a formal
education in it or read they still talk
of screenwriting as something that falls
from the sky that I don't want that
stuff you know I don't do plot you know
I'll I look I just read this someplace
and it just made me shake my head
somebody's these comments that flow into
things I think it was it was actually
was one of your clips and somebody
somebody down there was saying I hate
plot you know I want story and that poor
person obviously is not educated about
these things because plot and story are
the same bloody thing they are you a
story is plot plot is story maybe we can
get there in a minute or two but make
those mistakes and that's just that's
just ignorance you know and you can get
educated and you can learn the tools and
how to use them it is to be out there so
I'm going to create this beautiful big
intricate thing and not know the pieces
of it it's like going to say I'm going
to create this big beautiful house and I
know absolutely nothing about cement
electrical cabling roofing shingles
glass or you got to know all these
things before you can build a house and
I believe the same is true for really
good screenwriting for in falmouth I'll
throw out some some of the silly stuff
but useful useful stuff did you know for
instance that there are only four viable
goals in all of narrative screenwriting
yeah
when stopped escape or retrieve so oK
you've got an idea for a character your
hero or heroine great you got an idea
and they have okay now what is it they
want what they've got to have a goal to
pursue right well it has to fall into
the category of wind stop escape or
retrieve now these are big categories
and there are many versions of each
woman many permutations of each one so
it's not like it's that cut and dried
but it will appear to a lot of people
like it's that's too
dried for me but the point is this
there's only those four because those
four share something in common they all
provide a visible physical 3-dimensional
goal for a motion picture that will
result in a physical climax and
obligatory scene it precludes the use of
internal goals and that's one of the
things people have to get over an
internal goal that's great and it is
separate from what drives the movie you
need a physical visible goal each one of
those four goals has a finish line a
visible finish line and a goal like well
they want to feel better about
themselves that doesn't work on film it
just doesn't work and that there are
only four emotions mad sad glad and
scared you haven't heard that one yeah
again there are they they are you know
there's a lot of variations with demands
meds ed glad and scared there's many
permutations and and and dimensions
there but the way they are useful is
like this if you are building if you're
outlining something a section a
particular section here a goal sequence
or a particular scene the thing is the
way you guarantee that it's going to
have conflict and change in it and
change is one of the single most
important we could talk about that in a
minute to change is the power that makes
screenplays either work or not work
you got to quantify it but it can be
done wonderfully that if if the hero
lead character walks stomps jumps falls
into a scene and they are either mad sad
glad or scared
by the end of the scene they have to be
one of the others if they're mad when
they show up they have to be scared when
they walk away or if they're scared when
they show up they have to be glad when
they walk away because that
guarantees dramatic change within the
scene and it's a way of checking
yourself because we read a whole lot of
scenes which are just talk and they're
the same everything is the same at the
end as as it was at the beginning and
that is not a viable scene for visual
storytelling things like that they do
you know there are only 14 character
categories in all of dramatic writing
and all of narrative writing you have to
know the 14 categories and you have to
know how they work and how they
interrelate the puzzle pieces to create
plot how they advance how they can
advance a story I'm just curious what
sorry to interrupt but what are the what
are a few of the 14 just for instance
their words let me qualify there are 14
character Gadar character categories
that advance and serve story story is a
central character hero or heroine who
undertakes to do something physically do
something in order to achieve a visible
physical goal by the end kind of stuff
right and in that pursuit there are 14
other character categories who serve as
either helpers or hinder vers toward
that hero and they are mean like first
of all I mean the main categories are
our hero and adversary who adversary is
much unsung and under underappreciated
the adversary is critical and and and
and the point I mean without without
conflict you don't have a story there is
no story without conflict that's just it
you know so that adversary is key to the
creating of conflict and so it puts a
lot of weight on who the adversary is so
you got hero adversary then there is a
mentor a very wide and delicious
category
you know goes back to Joe Campbell and
and the assessment of the mythological
approach stuff that there's some of
those characters I mean he called the
adversary the shapeshifter that's some
more specific usage yes its adversary
shapeshifter is is somebody who appears
one thing on the outside and become
something else
that is one kind of adversary but not
the only kind so and then there's mentor
there's the love interest character this
is interesting the love interest
character I really go into this in
detail for folks for some I mean the
love interest character brings depth and
humanity and and and helps augments and
eases character growth forward for the
central character and it is the
least-used
character category of all the grad
students who pass through here yeah it
really is I think it's the character it
gets too close to home maybe their
experience you know in these things
emotional sensual experience is highly
limited or something what it is
something about it but that is a key
character and stories that work and you
have a romance subplot that love
interest character well when it's done
well it's one of the most powerful
things you can add to a story and then
there are helper follower allies and and
a sidekick sidekick is another category
very specific function is played by the
sidekick and and there's there is the
adversary agent see there is one
adversary adversary can only be one one
person human being or a personified
thing a monster that behaves like a
human being and thinks like a human
being but but one thing one human being
but they can also have all kinds of
adversary agents running around doing
the bidding of the adversary so in and
let's say Erin Brockovich they're
fighting this like toxic tort or
whatever anything and and so the the
workers of the plant or of the you know
are sort of the adversary agent because
they're maybe not the ones totally
calling the shots but they're working
for the people that are calling the
shots yes okay except for the ones that
turn to the good side you know who jump
over to the good people and and then
there's a group of characters called
gate Guardians and that's I would put
those people in the gate Guardian
category gate Guardian is a character
who this is this is from Campbell and
the mythological structure to gate
Guardian is a character who when first
met by the hero when first confronted by
the hero stops them says no you cannot
enter here but once the hero finds a way
to outsmart that gate Guardian it's
never brute force it's but when they
outsmart them and find a way to get
around them and continue their journey
after that the gate guardian becomes an
ally at first opposes and then assists
and I and a few more few more in there
too but see but the point is all of
these characters there's only fourteen
that that help you create a plot that
help move a story forward and any other
character that a particular writer wants
to plot you know I really like this
character you know they're kind of
interesting and peppy and zippy and they
talk funny and I like it if they do not
serve the story if they do not help
drive the plot forward axel cut them
lose them because they have to serve a
function Erik something you just said to
us off-camera was that when you do see
students again sometimes out in the the
public arena that they'll say you know I
always remember you encouraged me to
write badly with pride and how it worked
for them can we talk about that yeah
sure every time I walk into the class
the first evening all our classes are
evening evening classes and in the new
class the first year people there for
the first semester and I walk in
they're chattering away and trying to
get to know each other and so forth but
they haven't you know really had any
anything to do with me yet and I walk in
it was always weird and creepy because
as soon as I walk in deathly silence
falls everybody's waiting so I look very
austere and serious and I walk to the
whiteboard and I write on the whiteboard
and very very large letters write badly
with pride and then they laugh you know
everybody everybody laughs and it cuts
the ice and you know it works that way
and I turn around and I smile and I say
yes but I'm not kidding
for it is a critical importance for
writers to permanently give themselves
permission to write badly if writer's
block is all about expecting and
demanding of oneself perfection anything
any word any sentence it's gotta be
great it's got to be great
no that way lies right early death you
do that you'll end up freezing so solid
you'll never write again it is exactly
the opposite writing is a craft it's a
craft and how do you how do you
participate in a craft it's a craft that
it's you that exercised with words and
it is like in in I don't know statuary
or something you start out with a big
gooey pile of wet clay and you started
mush it you get your hands dirty you
know you get down in the mud and you're
mush it and squish it and then you start
making choices about as you shape it the
pieces you're not gonna need and so
forth and you go from there but you
start out with mess that's what we do as
writers we start with mess and then we
make choices first hundreds of choices
and then thousands of choices and before
we're done tens of thousands of
individual choices have been made but
you cannot make choices and you cannot
see what or choose what direction you
want your story to go in
or have you wanted to develop unless you
have a pile of words on the page so we
have exercises sometimes just let's try
it let's write as badly as we know how
and it's funny you read them aloud
everybody gets a laugh it's guy stuff
and what they find out is even when they
are trying to write badly because that's
what we're doing it's this little
exercise it still comes out funny it's
still it's it's not bad in other words
they're they're funny they're cute
they're weird they're quippy but even
writing badly they're not really writing
that badly at all if you write badly for
instance I'm trying to think of a good
example how about when I when I wrote my
book when I had trimmed it down nice and
tight and I thought I really had it
ready to go I had a hundred and a
hundred and twenty hundred and thirty
thousand words in the manuscript and I
called him up and said okay I'm ready to
go I've done my cutting and I've done to
my to it you know here it is one hundred
thirty thousand words and he laughed
publisher laughed and said no no Eric we
don't publish anything over seventy
thousand words and it was like this bolt
of horror that hit me I said wait a
minute are you actually telling me that
I now have to cut my book in half and he
said yeah actually I'm afraid I am so
for three or four days I was just
practically in a coma I was you know any
writer you know you're just you're
appalled but Wow what they make you to
do to your babies and then I got some
help I had somebody else a dear dear
friend who was good with editing take a
look at it and I seriously cut into it
one more time for editing I got it down
to eighty two thousand words not quite
there seventy thousand but I cut it by
forty forty-five percent of the book
that I thought was absolutely necessary
was gone and the book was better for it
was such a better book it was clearer
and it was cleaner and there were
so many swamps removed from it it was an
interesting experience but I had did not
realize you know you have to reject if I
I didn't realize how much work that was
yet to be done so writing is word
choices and a process of reassessing
critical to which means writers never
write alone never but what we spend a
lot of time alone in the writing process
but once we have something then we have
to and this is important this is
important to to new writers everywhere
you have to have a circle of people you
choose opinion of material you trust
it's one of the things that happens in
our program these people make friends
for life because then they rely on each
other's judgment because everybody knows
everybody's opinion grows to become
quite sophisticated about a material and
you can always call up one of your
buddies and say you want to do a script
swap you know you read mine I read yours
and what you get back frequently is not
what you want to hear we're all children
you know we all want to say oh that is
the greatest thing isn't that great and
that's never what you hear so you're
always eternally disappointed so you
hear objective good criticism of what
you've got and I always tell them 48
hours don't do anything for 48 hours
suffer fine you stay in bed whatever you
need to do in response to what you've
heard about your material and then sit
down and read it again cover to cover
and it will be revealed to you through
someone else's point of view what you
really have and all of a sudden it's
time to start editing again and
rewriting again you will get it and that
is what has happened there is the cycle
of subjective work to re objectification
because as the more you work on
something over time
the more you are in it you are drawn
into it and it becomes within you and it
is about you and you think you're doing
something great and then you take it out
and you get a slap in the face or two
you get you clears your eyes it clears
your vision very very well
you become reified and you approach the
material again with clean eyes for
another go-round and in my experience if
you really want good material and I'm
assuming we all do there's some we just
want Pat's on the head and all kind of
stuff but if you really want the
material to be good you have to go
through that cycle subjectivity re
objectification subjectivity rehabbed
four or five maybe six times then then
each time you know it gets better and it
gets a little better and it gets a
little better and you don't want to send
that anything out it's one of the
biggest mistakes people make sending out
material before it's finished so if
you're giving writers too permission to
write badly and and you're doing these
exercises and that's one of the first
things you write on the board where what
permission are you giving them with the
rewrites and how open are they to
rewriting most of them get I mean it's a
cliche but cliches are cliches because
they're true that writing is rewriting
and the only real way to teach writing
is through editing that's why I spent a
great deal of time on scripts and sample
editing and scratching out stuff and
throwing out scenes and telling them
people that you don't need this and this
is good expand it here and all that kind
of stuff because it's it's stuff that
people truly need to hear that's what
you get in a concentrated two-year four
semester program you get a heck of a lot
of practice in in a very short period of
time surrounded by very knowledgeable
people who can guide you is there wear
and tear on the nervous system you bet
that's that's kind of built in and Gary
but I so far I have never heard anybody
say they regret it or anybody complain
about it when they come out the other
end but the other thing I write on the
board a few weeks later yeah a few weeks
later is there is no such thing as a bad
screenplay only an unfinished one and
this is something I believe truly
believe just as strongly as I believe
about writing you know you got to write
badly with pride or you're never gonna
write anything it's you have to allow
yourself to do that but I think any idea
for a screenplay that is conflict based
you know this is the essential it has to
be conflict based but any idea for a
screenplay that is conflict based can be
made to work it can and bad screenplays
if they contain some conflict they can
all be made to work it's just that
they're sent out before they're finished
and when you send something out before
it's really finished you really only get
one good shot at it you know you kind of
burn it up and a lot of good ideas of
gone to the idea cemetery because of of
making that movie Erik in your book the
story solution you claim that you've
come up with a completely new paradigm
for writing screenplays and novels we're
curious what that is just a quick word
on how it came about first okay because
I know it's pretty outrageous for a lot
of people to be from my to be claiming
that you know what what new Under the
Sun can there possibly be you know from
for a long time for years before I
became a professor here while I was
still a full-time screenwriter I was
teaching at UCLA Extension writers
program which is the largest such
writing program in the world and it's
really great really good people teach
there and it was a way to get out of the
house
night a week you know out of my room out
of my office and I was working with
people who were really bright and really
talented in various and sundry ways they
you know great characters warm
three-dimensional super dialog that just
kind of crackles and pops but when they
finally turned in their final project at
the end of the of the quarter I guess
the quarter system there and I read
their scripts they just laid there that
they were flat the story wasn't
happening or going anywhere they would
have three or four events and then try
to stretch that out over you know 110
pages or have with the whole screenplay
would be and I gave them the books we
read the books we went over it in the
structure over and over the classic
structure and and and Joseph Campbell
and all of that and yet when they sat
down to write it it just somehow didn't
gel into a concept or command of screen
story structure and screenwriting is
screen story structure more than it is
anything else
right so I went looking for you know as
people do for patterns there had to be a
way to teach story construction to not
to the exclusion of all else but focus
only on finding an objective objectified
way to teach story construction this is
how you build a house board one you know
that kind of stuff and I looked you know
hundreds and hundreds of films and yes I
began to see a pattern that I hadn't
heard anybody talk about before or
mentioned before or hadn't read about
before and and I kind of codified it put
it together as a paradigm and cleaned up
the questions that it raised kind of
stuff and I kept looking and I began
more and more convinced and then I did I
to prove myself wrong I mean
this I thought was a real important step
so I went back searching through movies
that had been hit movies that had you
know emotionally affected audiences all
over the world from pretty far back I
went far back as 1929 Buster Keaton the
general I don't know if you ever saw it
it was one of his last if not his last
silent film it is you know something of
a masterpiece of the silent era same
thing the same beats the same moment the
same sequences accomplishing the same
stuff so I codified it and began to
teach it in in in the grad courses
people were rather cynical about such a
thing to begin with but what I found out
over a few years of working on codifying
it simplifying it you know packaging it
in a way that was understandable and
useful as a tool because that's what it
is it's just a tool and darn good one
useful one too
one by one I won them all over and I
proved it yes it's true and it was like
an interesting experience for all of us
because again it is it is about
discovery just let me try this okay for
just just a few minutes one of the
single most important aspects of
screenwriting any long form narrative a
novel writing to it just screenwriting
in particular is change things thus
everything in the story must keep
changing as it flows it got it has to be
different five ten minutes from now than
then at what the circumstances were
previously ten minutes ago it has to
keep changing and I I had came to
believe there had to be a pattern of
change and what I discovered was this
this gets a little numeric you know
there is stick with me for this because
it's it's important and I think enormous
ly useful three acts okay and in a
screenplay you've got three actors first
act in act 1 I noticed there are six
sequences following one another that I
called I came to call hero gold
sequences here's the definition for a
hero gold sequence a hero gold sequence
is any two to seven page section of your
screenplay in which and through which
your hero or heroine pursues one
short-term goal physical short-term goal
only one as one step toward achieving
the overall story goal right just just
that little piece of it and at the end
of that seven or so you nothing is exact
you know but seven or so pages something
happened or some discovery is made by
this hero that I call fresh news in
other words they turn up something that
was unknown by them and by us by the
audience about what they are doing that
puts an end to that current single goal
and offers up a new short-term physical
single goal to be pursued in the next
step and that there are six of these
hero goal sequences six little
individual pursuits of individual
specific goals in the entirety of Act
one and what we call there's many names
for this plot point one there's the the
first major turning point that kind of
thing I call it stunning surprise one
when stunning surprise one happens which
ends Act one officially and dramatically
ends Act one
and kicks the hero forward tumbling
head-over-heels
into Act two I call it sunny surprise
one because that should be I believe the
emotional impact on both the hero and
the audience it needs to be emotional
and it needs to be impactful not
abstract that always happens in here a
goal sequence six always and it
continues in the first half of the
second act there are six more hero goal
sequences and hero goal sequence number
12 always contains the midpoint sequence
that's a separate discussion the
midpoint is a fascinating part of movies
that work and it's it's it's rich and
layered with things that go on relative
to character growth and relative to the
plot being you know bumped up to the
next level and all but it always happens
in number 12 in the second half of Act
two there are six more wonder of wonders
there are six more hero goal sequences
in here real goal sequence eighteen
always contains stunning surprise to not
seventeen not nineteen eighteen in every
movie that works for audiences in ever
in other words every hit movie that you
can analyze because it's doing something
right this is the pattern and then in
Act three it's the only act where it can
vary where the numbers can vary and in
Act three you have between two and five
hero goal sequences I don't recommend
five five is good movies have been made
with five like as good as it gets which
has to be you know one of my favorite
romantic comedies kind of stuff it has
five here with all sequences in a rather
extended act three but the audience is
getting antsy and it's time to get out
by then I I the standard the average of
movies that work is 2121 here with goal
sequences 18 for acts one and two and
then another three in Act three this is
a way I know it sounds kind of weird and
mathematical at this point but this is a
way of quantifying change it tells you
in advance this must happen in these few
pages there it also goes beyond that I
mean people were asking you well and
what specifically happens in each one of
these can you nail that down in a
general way yeah I do that in the book
you know I said well these things
usually happen in here real goal
sequence number four you know that kind
of stuff but that's up for grabs and up
for people to play with but structurally
the bones are these 2223 hero goal
sequences laid out in this exact way and
they don't change why are there so many
screenwriters opposed to structure are
they hurting or helping themselves with
this viewpoint there are there are a lot
of people I always will be and some of
them got Tom Stoppard himself no less a
writer than tom is really opposed to
education you know kind of this
education that is now offered in
graduate schools for screenwriting and
all that but he can afford to be you
know if you're born a genius
you know okay go for it you can say
anything you want do anything you write
brilliantly and it's fine for them it's
natural but for more for most of us poor
unfortunates down here below the peak of
Olympus yeah we have to work a little
harder at it I think I think it is a
misconception of what there is to be
learned they are that many many people
have always done it a certain way and
they sit and suffer and they think
there's a muse that comes down some
people may be very very intuitive about
this story stuff
and for them fine yeah yeah it can work
but what I find is for the vast majority
of people who want to be writers of
screenplays or novels that's not the
case there are tools tools tools there
are tools one needs to master before you
are going to play inspirational and
fantastic
orchestral music for instance you're
going to compose and play don't you need
to learn how to play the piano well yeah
that helps don't you lead to need to
know about music and the theories of
music and Composition hey it would help
you'd save yourself a lot of time in
trouble if you do that and I believe
very much that it's the same with
screenwriting there's so much to learn
there really is and the folks that tend
to think that way and defended ok that's
the way they've always worked I get that
you know that's the way you want to work
great go pet that do it but I believe
they are bringing into their own lives
far more emotional suffering than then
needs to be there they it's there's not
the Muse folks if there is no muse
it's up to you to come up with a decent
idea that you can then pull out the
correct tools to start shaping into
something that will work and bring
emotional sustenance and release for an
audience I think you had a blog post
that I just skimmed the beginning of it
and it's just that you you think you put
you know we wake up the the birds are
chirping we feel great and we're
inspired and we are gonna write and we
get into like page 27 and we've hit a
roadblock so is this what we're talking
about here sort of like how to find a
way out of that roadblock because we
know that okay if we're at page 47 we're
at this point in this story are we at
the midpoint by the way which is the
interesting yeah yeah 40-ish is 47 issue
it's about the midpoint yes I have
always said no plan no detailed plan no
Oscar it's just not going to happen if
you're going to build a house especially
an intricate one as one as intricate as
as a screenplay for a really good movie
you have to have architectural
renderings that take it down to the
tiniest dimension and detail and piece
of equipment that is going to be used
you have to be organized about it
disorganized people as a rule don't do
all that well as as writer screenwriters
again this is not everybody there are in
fact geniuses don't you just hate them
out there who can do this stuff just
instinctively without even thinking
about it but there's a handful of them
living on planet Earth at any given time
and of course they can't see it from our
perspective you know the gee maybe you'd
have to work at it but yes there is a
lot of work and a lot to be known and
and isn't it better if you lay the
pieces out you know you have a puzzle
puzzle board before you and you have all
you know the dark pieces here and the
light pieces here and you began to
search and see and fit together
something that is going to be a whole
picture by the time you're through that
is a systematic way of doing something
that is very difficult to do and I would
argue the tools the tools quantifying
change understanding the 14 character
categories knowing that there are 10
modes of plot coming out of how many
heroes and and what the hero's
relationship is to other characters
there's only 10 of those and once you
have an idea pick your 10 you know pick
which of the 10 that's going to save you
a lot of time and a lot of agony and I
would also throw this out
I would challenge listen I I am open as
anybody to learn here I'm a lifelong
learner myself if if someone thinks I'm
wrong here or has an instance where and
if they can prove that I am wrong I'd be
very interested to hear it I really
would
if you think you've found a 15th
category for instance if you've taken a
look at the 14 and understand what is
contained in the 14 categories if you
can come up with a brand new character
category I would love to be one of the
first to hear about it really usually
and I offer that to the students all the
time on time usually when I hear back
when they bring things up rather
enthusiastically bless their hearts it's
usually from a misunderstanding of the
14 or it's a misunderstanding of of what
I'm saying relative to here at goal
sequences and things like that but it's
okay it I'm I'm happy about hearing
about ways in which I might be incorrect
with this stuff there is room for growth
in all of your classes growing up was
there one instructor that said something
to you that really changed your way of
thinking about writing and do you
remember that moment and what it was
that it where it really popped it made
sense could be something very basic and
be something more elaborate mmm
whether you were sitting in class
whether it was notes they gave you one
of the things about being at the MFA
program in playwriting this was so it
was still fairly fairly early on for me
at UCLA they as all universities they're
very big on employing inviting even in
as lecturers and you know as part-time
people people known and it greatly
experienced in the industries and they
would come in
and teach a course for instance a
graduate course there was a world famous
playwright in particular who who came in
and did this course a wonderful
wonderful man and a major talent and I
took the course and it wasn't it wasn't
the ultimate word of wisdom that's not
what I took away what I took away from
that course is every writer and every
life is different and in a way sometimes
that we do not even want to hear it is
truly up to us writers have in their
core hopefully the ability we've you
know we've been alone all our lives and
our thoughts to stand alone because
hearing about other people's journeys in
a personal way these these people just
weren't I mean this particular
individual too was a wonderful soul but
basically what he did is he told old war
stories for all semester long and what
we were writing we wrote on our own we
were it was up to us in the entire time
as a matter of fact that I was at UCLA
nobody made any serious attempt to teach
me us the toolkit or approach or
structure of writing full-length plays
it was all touchy-feely and all up to
you and for a while there I was a bit
upset about that a bit ticked about that
it what did cost money and all that
stuff but yes I learned I learned what
they didn't it perhaps intend to teach
which is one person's journey is going
to be different from yours now this is
kind of the opposite of what you are
asking for you know this ultimate gem or
jewel of wisdom but I think it is a
jewel of wisdom that these are good
brilliant
accomplished artists
who are most sincere and their ability
to share but how they've done it and
what they did be able to share that with
these up-and-coming writers before them
in the grant program but I came away
feeling they didn't have a whole lot to
share and that said okay okay I get that
we will make our own path do you think
because they were so busy doing that
they had a hard time articulating how
they did it or no I don't know I think
most of them were instinctive writers
they didn't codify it and that's why
when I came to teach later came to teach
screenplay I was you know kind of
obsessed with this has to be you know
this is teachable these are smart people
they can learn if we can make this
teachable it can be taught I mean there
are certain levels at which skill talent
it helps to have talent but we all know
I certainly think I hope most people
understand that it's not necessarily the
most talented writers who end up you
know getting their scripts sold and and
and even made that's not how it works
they had they they come up with ideas
for stories Hollywood buys stories not
particulars crypts by particular writers
and their stories that take people on a
specific emotional journey knowing that
most likely they're going to come out
feeling good at the end yes yeah yeah
less less so with feeling good at the
end now today then once upon a time
have you seen life like we just saw that
recently have you seen life yet speaking
of a negative ending yeah but there's
still the gems but I get it I felt like
after maybe 9/11 things change but then
that's a whole nother topic but no yeah
good point many new writers say that
it's nearly impossible to get their
scripts to people that actually have the
power to buy them or greenlight them
that that's their problem but the access
yeah what are your thoughts on that and
that's the reason they're not me sorry
yeah I would I would say they don't know
how lucky they are as of today it
depends you have to get used to the
system you have I've for instance back
in back in the day back in my day there
was one way into Hollywood TV film one
way and that was through an agent's
front door and that agents front door
had layers and layers of guardians
before it and that was all so
frustrating you know in a similar way
but very very frustrating to Gideon but
now what you have you have a more
creative path let me put it this way
contests screenwriting contests have now
been around long enough to separate the
wheat from the chaff
you know the good ones a year after year
have gotten stronger because you know
more people believe in them and the less
good ones although they're all sincere I
know they're all sincere have kind of
fallen and fallen by the wayside but the
test is this every time I hear that I
mean yes I have great sympathy for that
I understand that I remember when I was
coming up myself and what it felt like
and it was infuriating and frustrating
but the number one reason why you are
not making it is the material is not yet
good enough because you if you're not
especially if you're not reading you
know that reading the stuff that's out
there you have no way of knowing how
good good has to be in order to get
noticed and coming in you have to be
better than most of the people who are
now making a living at it
in order to get noticed even but the
contests offer you know the device talk
about Ryabkov a concrete way to do that
work on it and work on it and work on it
until you've got something you're ready
to test but now pick your contests
carefully the first time you try it out
pick smaller contests more more fringing
I mean do your research they should be
decent upstanding contests and so forth
try it out try it out did you make the
quarterfinals or were you swept away you
know in in the first pass through okay
if that happens you have learned
something it's not ready and you keep
working on it and you keep working on it
and finally when you know you get to the
mid-level ranks and let's say it gets
your your script gets to the
quarterfinals okay but it did not make
the top 10 or top 15 fine you've learned
something more go back take a vacation
for a couple of weeks try not to think
about it then read it again make more
notes and go back to work on it and it
is a way to that's the thing see what
what what a lot of neophyte
screenwriters new screenwriters don't do
or don't pursue which is you have got to
be as a writer as a craftsperson you
must be relentless in your goal of
creating quality material for instance
I'll give you for instance and maybe
that was sort of I'm working with a
young lady right now who was one of our
grad students a few years a couple two
three years ago she's been my assistant
class assistant and stuff like that so
we know each other pretty well
she took her thesis screenplay from I
don't know three years ago and I read it
and I told her you got a great idea here
you know you really do I believe in this
idea and we had conversations about you
know there's no such thing as a bad
screenplay only an unfinished one and
all that and I gave her some pointers
and you know scribbled things on the
pages and she went back and she wrote it
again this is a feature film and I
looked at it
this is better this is a little better
and I went through I did you know the
sample editing and scribble-scribble and
all this kind of stuff and then she
takes it and she comes back and it's a
little bit better she has been through
that process well in this case with me
oh it must be six times now I mean years
have passed I mean that was she this she
she had a draft of this when she went up
for her thesis three years ago right but
I'll tell ya and I'm I'm reading it once
again I'll probably be looking at it
again this weekend she is so close so
close what I would really like to I kept
telling her keep track of don't lose
your draft of your of your first draft
don't lose a copy of your first draft
because a day is coming I would like to
have that in my hand and your final
draft and put that together in a binder
and use this in class have people read
the first draft and now read the last
draft and that I believe could be a
wonderful wonderful exploration of
teaching and screenwriting because this
has become viable she is now close to
having a an entirely shootable
casting really good social commentary
screenplay
what changed in those six drafts over
the three years or how for many craft
craft her mastery of I mean what most of
them do is they write what they mean
when they come to dialogue people just
blurt it out and it's called on-the-nose
dialogue that's one of the things you
teach stop it people do not talk like
that people talk around what they mean
not that there can't be confrontation
and stuff like that under certain
emotional circumstances yes but it was
dialogue and less is more in terms of
the amount of dialogue in description it
was about the use of language and
vocabulary in description using
irrelevant words the and
there there's a whole list of there's
the nine most utterly useless words I
got it back there on a sheet I pass out
sometimes all that is is filler all that
does is slow the reader down it is
developing a style in the way you
describe and and offer exposition and
description in in scene with seen
heading slug lines and then what we're
looking at and stuff like that drawing
people in where you put things the plot
building the plot in an ever better way
you can do more here you could do more
here that's what's been going on for all
those years so you liked her initial
idea of the story
absolutely and it's so and it was in
very rough form very rough form she had
written badly with pride and in Neath
underneath that there had been there's
just something that really struck me you
know this is this is worth saying and
this is important to say it's a social
commentary piece it's not like there's a
big market out there for social
commentary pieces there isn't but say
okay but it has to be done incredibly
well to catch the eyes you want to catch
we said ever gonna be made I don't know
if it's ever going to be made or not
that's out of our hands
but I am so proud of her boy she has got
a work sample for the ages so and you've
let her know not not too soon because
once she takes this brilliant idea and
it's not ready that's the end of it that
is correct time and again oh she was
planning two years ago to send it off to
one of the majors I don't know I don't
know what's it's a scriptable loser or
what one of the majors you know and she
has to take one more look at it before
she sent it off I said I'd think you're
it's self-defeating to send this off yet
and she there was a small contest it's
the BFA broadcast Education Association
has a student thing every year
and they have contests short-film
contest of four students and scripts and
so forth I said try it there try it
there and she did and she learned some
stuff she learned some stuff and she
also learned that that sometimes judges
can be jerks and that's part of the mix
too but she learned she kept working and
he got better that is how you write
everybody who says you know you got a
screen once when I was coming up I said
you got a cranked out a brand new
screenplay every six months that's a
that is insane I'm sorry you can't do
good work if you're doing that no you
have to live with it you have to grow
with it you have to be able to go back
and read it again and again and yet
again it drives my wife nuts when I was
working on the book you know I was
already was ready to senator debris the
publisher and she said you're sitting
down to read it again what is wrong with
you I said honey you you married a
madman I mean that that goes with the
territory that's what writers do and I
read it again and I found mistakes and I
fixed them it's endless
so the the best thing for a writer is to
have been born a bit obsessive
compulsive it's like that is a trait
that the craft requires of us
you don't just - it off you don't and do
it well what are the most common
mistakes new screenwriters make
okay there's a list but the most let's
just say the three most common ones that
I see are number one not enough story
again it's that old thing characters can
be wonderful dialogue can be sparkling
and even funny as heck but if the story
lays there just flat as a pancake that
story is not going anywhere it's it's a
weak story number two would be passive
central character that kids killed more
scripts than just about anything I've
ever seen and weak story and passive
central character they go together they
really go to get fit together to a
passive central character is a is a hero
or heroine you know the lead down the
middle who doesn't really do anything
and life and the story happen to them
they do not happen to anything or anyone
and that is that is a one way to put
your audience to sleep very very quickly
audience heroes have to be active they I
mean the hero is the audience you build
that you build a story so that the hero
is even with lots of flaws and
everything fine yes make them human but
they have certain qualities character of
the of character and of circumstance
they have to be brave that is absolutely
essential but you can put them in you
know unfair injury we care about people
who are being unjustly dealt with
they're in a situation of danger they're
funny
they have a sense of humor that always
helps loved by other people there is
this kind of list of things you can do
to keep characters interesting that
allows us to like them and once we start
seeing the nature of of the hero or
heroines major problem and the major
impossible task before them hopefully on
about page six or eight
the audience the audience becomes one
person each of us sitting alone and we
project ourselves psychologically
project ourselves into the hero and then
we're along for the ride and if that
hero doesn't do anything or doesn't want
anything and other people do all this
stuff and all the people that come in
all the secondary characters are the
witty fun urbane you know loquacious and
they're there that and joking and funny
they're all the funny characters while
basically your central character is more
or less wallpaper it's it's dead and
that is related to something something
else which is the adversary when that
happens in a script almost always the
problem is there is no adversary or
there is no powerful adversary adversary
is so critical people need to work on
their adversary until it is the
adversary should be the strongest person
in the story I'm I you know when I was
coming up if they oh they have to be
equal they have to be equal in power to
the hero no they have to be much more
powerful than the hero
it has to look for most of the movie it
has to look like the hero has no bloody
way of defeating this adversary or
surmounting this the the problems being
presented by this adversary but they do
it they they think them and they out try
them and drive and they can make it
happen and that's a story with great
conflict with a hero who is doing things
who sucks us in emotionally that we can
ride along happily for the journey and
that's how that's how the good ones work
which that's probably more than more
than to through and made that three or
four but the the next the third I think
I would say is getting it out there too
soon okay
that's what destroys most screenplays
it's hard you know writing this a
screenplay a feature-length screen pit
but heavens that's hard really hard
and it's not necessarily all pleasant
undertaking labor it it hurts you tear
your hair out you pound your head
against the wall sometimes literally and
but finally you got a draft oh god I did
it here it is here it is like I'm gonna
get it out quickly as I can and that's
the time of great danger you know you
can't just send it out it is not ready
guaranteed it is not ready
is there really this database of cover I
mean of scripts slow so I mean really it
so some sounds like you know the sort of
the medical record database they have
one on scripts to this like oh yes I see
Eric Edson yes on this date he sent us
this no no the coverage was horrible or
something I mean really this exists well
I mean I I have to confess now it's been
some years since I was in the thick of
it of this but I don't think a whole lot
has really changed in except they've got
more technological they've gotten better
ways to keep track of stuff and yeah
back then you had one basically one shot
because one kind the person you're
sending it to if you finally and get an
agent to say okay you know I'll take a
look leave me alone
or or if the producer or a friend of a
friend or whatever like that most often
they're not going to read it they're
going to hand it to their reader and I
remember those early on when I was
getting phone calls back from producers
and they were obviously reading from
notes they had obviously not read the
script themselves they were working from
readers notes okay but they have their
time issues too and they've got to have
use their time as best they can but yeah
if you get a bad report first time in it
is filed
now it's digital digital eyes and you
never know ultimately you know what
company becomes joined with what company
and sometimes the people they just know
each other even if they're at different
companies and I did this pass through
and they now send me over the report and
yes those those reports get disobey
again disseminated what if you change
the
the script let's suppose you started one
called angels flight and then you said
you know what and this got a pass and a
pass and so you decided to change it to
birds of a feather and I'm just totally
making this - yeah but and and and so
birds of a feather has been looked at
and you've worked on it much more and
you've had more time but the story is
very similar I would I would say my
instinct is that you have probably done
severe probably irreparable damage to
your career to resend something yes
okay under a different title Wow because
they have the plot you know that's one
of the things that reader does they
outline the entire plot before they say
and you know whether it good bad or
indifferent no I don't don't do it don't
just go around changing titles because I
don't know they don't like it they don't
trust it then they don't trust you
yes ah so that's the bottom line okay
yes if you really worked on some let
first of all that time pass you're not
gonna go back at him why were you really
I've rewritten it and it's really really
good now and it's five months later and
no forget it
put it away and then when the time comes
you know if there may be and what
they're looking for in any given year
the wheel keeps turning and you know the
nature of the material that they're
looking for and then do it honestly say
look you know I tried this out on you
two three years ago I have been working
I mean I still believe in the idea and
I've been working on it I think it's a
great deal better or you go to somebody
who hasn't read it before because
there's always somebody who hasn't read
it before and say you know a friend of
yours mm-hmm Nancy or something like
that she read it and she read she quite
liked it or find another way a back door
like maybe the friend Nancy but I
wouldn't change the title so be upfront
play by their warrant because it could
hurt you just
yeah you need you need to be upfront
about it yeah why do you think people
are scared to be upfront
sometimes Liars get away with it
we have examples we have exact dude we
don't have to go yeah yeah plenty
sometimes Liars get away with it but
people especially people in this
business I'm not saying they're all
greatly talented but a lot of them are a
lot of them are enormous Lee they just
have different talents than than writers
you know another a different kind of
creativity sure and they mean well you
know they're they're they're not
inherently you know dishonest or scuzzy
people or anything like that but they
make mistakes and you you need to learn
from their mistakes and they also
amazingly they have long memories too
long long time ago in a land far away
and I was a struggling screenwriter and
I was cranking out original material
that was my thing they figured the only
way I could make my I mean I wasn't you
know a pusher and a pounder and a Yeller
and the only way I was gonna make myself
a inevitable was to keep writing and
keep writing and make myself inevitable
through a pile of good to great scripts
and that's pretty much the path the path
I took and I had a great idea about a
war that takes place at the very
beginning of the Civil War it was a
Allan Pinkertons story and I pitched it
all over town I had a good agent at the
time pictured all at my place yeah yeah
good story good story we don't want it
we don't make at the moment the word was
we don't make historical pictures at
that time they were very expensive
hey costumes Hey sets locations means
you know a moolah so I said fine and
my agent advised me to move ok fine we
know move on and I said you know I want
to take give me a couple of months
because I'm gonna write this anyway I
really like this story I think this is a
really good story and I want to write it
he said you're nuts but ok so I wrote it
and I had really liked it and we tried
it again an in script form and you know
got the same response nobody wanted to
do it and I said ok but I know in my
heart it's a good script so I put it
away it was I forget exactly but 8 or 9
years later a producer under very
charming sweet producer by the Wendy
diamond was her name she calls me up and
says you know Eric you know that that
Civil War thing you had do you still
have that is is that available is it
available she said would you could you
send that over at that time she was
working at TNT I was producing with with
another you know I'm strong a very
strong producer at TNT and at TNT it was
TNT that brought back the epic the
historical epic that's part of what they
were into it I guess he was interested
in you know that kind of material or
something so I sent it over and within I
don't know eight or eight or ten weeks
we had a deal then within 18 or 20 weeks
they were in pre-production and that's
one of the ones my originals had got
made so how did they have a copy of the
script again I'm sorry you would sent it
out but she wasn't Paul she didn't have
a copy
she only remembered it she remembered
she had read the whole script back in
the day she was somewhere else yeah she
was somewhere else doing is doing
something else but I guess the point
here for screenwriters everywhere is all
of your original material has a shelf
life it's not that you give it a shot
everybody says no and you contemplate
suicide and
you put it in the closet and carry on
right it's that's not it the cycles of
what they are willing to purchase or
option or consider actually making the
cycles keep changing at one point nobody
would touch a historical epic with a
ten-foot pole and some years later there
was somebody looking for one and my my
career during those years at 23 years
whatever was my career as a screenwriter
went around three times you know hot to
cold to hot to cold you know three times
three full times and every single time
when things were cooling down things
sometimes that had nothing to do with me
you know a project goes bad and you
happen to be associated with it or have
had something to do with it and then it
splashes over on you people cool for a
while every single time the way I got
back in the game was with a new original
screenplay that's your line of defense
you can't be lazy you cannot be lazy
you must continually be working on
original material you don't need luck to
be a successful screenwriter aren't
there people that look into it or it
just seems that way I'm one of those
people who believes in you create your
own luck is luck a factor any you know
in anything the stars sometimes have to
come into alignment before something
becomes possible but the thing about
luck is you have to be ready for it when
it arrives and that is where craft comes
in yes I remember I just I got just
plain lucky several times along the way
but then I had a closet full of work
that I could that I could use and prove
and and verify that I was really good at
this
that I was the one worth taking a shot
with it's not just luck you can't blame
it on luck if you're not making headway
you takes a lot of time and you have to
be improving your craft forever
the thing about screenwriting is truly
then the band the best ones will say
this I've heard it from the best ones
you never master this craft never it's
too intricate but if you master your
tools you can you can continue to have
pleasure in it live in it live the lives
I've lived hundreds of lives you know
it's just it's it's a very rewarding
thing to do even when it's rough you
know even when even when you're not
selling but it's it's well worth doing
and when luck comes and if you're around
long enough if you're at it long enough
opportunity will come but you must be
ready to make the maximum of that
opportunity
no no deer-in-the-headlight time you
know when the headlight hits
you are ready to tap-dance and you've
got your scripts you have studied
pitching you know how to pitch that is
we haven't really gone into that but
that is really key to this business and
there's no way around it yeah yeah I
reckon I recommend my dear friend
Michael Higgs book what is it selling
your story in 60 seconds I think is
approximately his title you got to know
this stuff and I don't care if you're
shy I'm you know you can still learn to
pitch a 60 120 second story tell your
story and there's a there's this thing a
story an old story that goes around that
when when we're practicing working on
pitching in courses and stuff and people
sometimes having fun so other people are
upset by it and
and I say just just be as nervous as you
want to be it's not about pitching is
not about not being nervous it's really
not said once upon a time there was this
creative executive that worked for a
very very powerful producer and he comes
bursting into the producers office one
day and he says Alice I just heard the
most dynamic story I have heard in five
years it's perfect there's a star as a
role for a star it's funny it's touching
it's just the best story I've heard for
ages but I had to I had to pass because
the the writer was nervous they don't
give a damn if you were halting or if
you are nervous they don't give a damn
if you have trouble pitching and that
you know you're doing something that
everything in you wants to resist tell
them your story whoever you are there is
room in this business for everybody tell
them your story
being nervous as you want to be they are
in the story business if your story is
ready if you've checked away and shaped
it into a into a pitch Abul form really
a powerful story and if your timing you
luck and timing if your timing is right
don't worry about it it'll all take care
of itself what advice do you have for a
screenwriter when they sit down to start
writing a screenplay what are some
things they should have already done
before they type that first page whether
it's outlining they should have beside
them a list of the 100 most recent
screenplays that they have read the
published ones the successful ones okay
I'll give you a break make it 50 you are
not ready to write until you are very
well-read and well-versed in the
literature you are proposing to create
and in this in this place its
screenwriting
I would say systematize your
organization the first thing you have to
do see a really bad habit that most
screenwriters have is they got a great
idea and they're cooking and they just
start writing screenplay I'm writing
screenplay pages to a boy and it's fun
but it's going nowhere ultimately
without a plan and a very well thought
out the hard work is in the outline and
it has to be a very complete outline and
you have to have confidence that all
story problems have been addressed so
the first thing you have to do is the
dirty work the outline write yourself I
would say here real goal sequences
because I happen to think it and I
happen to know that it works but however
you know beat sheet however they do it
have you very complete outline and then
good bloody luck it's it's it's a lot of
work and then I would also say yeah you
write it on a little piece of paper and
tape it above your desk write badly with
pride no no writer's block none just
write badly with pride write a piece of
piece of junk you know if you haven't
give you just sitting there staring at
the wall for an hour okay what would you
write if you were just really writing
trash really writing garbage go for it
because you never know when the real
idea is the depth of what you are doing
will be sparked you just don't know you
don't know and there's so many things
you have the tone yeah I'm working I'm
beginning to have some fun at this stage
of things I have you know some some
original screenplays of course as it
turns out that never sold and yeah
frequently what happens is the stuff you
like the most that's the stuff that
doesn't sell and there are three or four
of them that I'm I want to turn into in
turn into novels
before my clock and race have been run
and I started on one there's some months
back and I've been working a month and a
half now on the first five pages every
day I do it's it's yeah I've kind of
fell into it but it's what a Hamming way
did everyday he started at page one and
that's what I have to do you know by
instruction being instructed by him but
also by a nature I every day I started
page one you can do that for the first
40 or 50 pages you reach a point you
know it doesn't work anymore but what
you do by that what you gain by that is
do not be in a hurry to zoom onward you
because those first 5 to 10 pages are
the most important pages and the holes
and the whole thing in a novel in a
screenplay you either convince your
audience it's worth to come along or
reader it's it's worth their time to
come along for this journey with you or
not that you II either they trust you by
then or they don't so in the search for
tone rhythm the use of language and
character it's amazing spending five
pages with your central character in
this case what you can learn about that
character and doing the same five pages
over and over and over and over and over
you'll learn a heck of a lot about your
hero this is invaluable as you move
forward so I would say also don't rush
Eric was the best screenplay that you've
ever read and was that script ever
turned into a movie mm-hmm that's a
tricky one Best Screenplay
that I have personally read I would have
to go back to Erin Brockovich I would
say I mean you know there's hundreds of
thousands of others out there that I
have not read but of the ones that I
have premeditatedly sat down with and
read more than once and made notes about
and so forth I would have to say it was
there in Brockovich and that's why I use
it the way I do in class Susannah grant
taught me a great deal about
screenwriting in that one script but
what was the other part of the question
oh well that was the script turned into
a film Oh most definitely yeah it was
definitely definitely done so but you
know there's something else here if I
might I I encourage people and point
them in the direction of studying good
movies the screenplays of good movies
but just as valuable every bit as
valuable and in some cases more valuable
is studying the screenplays if you can
get your hands on them but certainly
studying the movies that bomb movies
that are really bad because they can
teach you just as much as the good stuff
they can teach you what not to do what
doesn't work and the idea to really get
good at the craft is to get build for
yourself an analytical eye and if you
want to get good at analysis look at
some bet the movies you hate I mean
everybody comes down to Iowa what's your
worst favorite you know what the worst
movie I ever saw
oh my god oh no I said okay get that
movie and I want you to see it three
times and they freaked out that better
go spend time with that basic yeah and
all this kind of stuff and I say guys
let's think this thing through if you
really hate it you have to know why just
telling me you hate it accomplishes
nothing you have learned nothing what
you have to learn is why do you hate it
what ways in what ways has it let you
down as a creative undertaking nobody
sets out to write
a bear and make a bad movie nobody they
may set out to be I will you know will -
this piece often it'll be in a whale get
some money out of the market yeah but
they don't intend that it be a bad movie
movies go bad for a whole a whole swath
and stack of reasons and we need to know
why we need to know why I was I'm not
I'm not gonna mention some titles I was
thinking about some titles I don't want
to go there but I've learned an awful
lot from screenplays and movies that are
not good why are they not good learn
that and then you're growing as a
screenwriter how do we know our own
writing level the level that we're at we
all think were good at something or
excellent at something we see the world
through a certain lens it fits together
with our experiences so we think we're
making sense we think it's brilliant in
terms of our life experience but how do
we really know or maybe we won't
I don't think you should know you're one
of the few in the class who are really
good because that's kind of putting a
cap on yourself oh I I would say and we
do talk about this I'm going to point
out to them in terms of as will
workshopping everybody's work and yes
everybody's at different levels that I
say we all come to this room from
different places we all have been
writing for different periods of time
some are closer to the beginning than
others some have already done some stuff
sold some stuff so it's going to be we
have we're making allowances for that
that nobody will be on the same level
and I would say that I would just say
don't worry about your level it's not
relevant to the process of learning to
master a craft and you know in a
difficult craft at that
just do the work in front of you bu and
write what you have to write because the
thing ultimately with writing and then
you know the beauty of it is even when a
story is derivative
perhaps you got an idea for a plot B say
yeah no no no I you know I've seen that
the score of times before or through the
decades kind of stuff and I would say
yes but no one can write it exactly the
way you would write it
it's not about level it's about
individual point of view and insight
into the human condition and that is I
would say in all time on all things in
it for all times it is to be encouraged
that's what we do we seek ourselves and
what we write even even when we're
writing for money for pay and you can
overdo that but I think you need to be
doing it some of that in absolutely
everything you write because what was
that that was some some book came out
and in the 1930s I forget who wrote it
who said there are basically 30 36 plots
in all of literature that's it well
that's what the thing is with genre you
know genre gonna writer Western well
that's been done a few hundred a few
thousand times hasn't it well you will
do it your way you will do it the way in
which it has not been done before or if
that's not how it turns out keep working
on it if you wish or put it in the
drawer and you will have learned some
lessons about writing and yourself along
the way but I'm the level thing you know
it's just that we running different
races there's so much levels you know
it's like some people started sooner
than other people so of course they're
going to be a
but I would admonish writers neophytes
and and experienced ones don't worry
about that you can make yourself nuts
worrying about the level because you
will always be writing what you want to
write unless you get hired to do it for
a job but you will be writing what you
want to write the way you want to write
it now just work to make it the best you
can make it be that's all and one day
you may surprise yourself just when you
think maybe you aren't so good and this
happened oh we all go in cycles yeah
this this should be mentioned too I mean
you know up one day and down the next
day suicidal I mean I mean this is art
this is writers you know welcome to the
club on that big wheel the emotional
journey of what it is what we do but you
are also learning whether this art form
is for you or not along the way are you
in for the long haul that's the only
question you need to keep asking
yourself am I getting enough food out of
this enough creative food and juice and
sense of you know that growing sense of
command incremental command of a much to
be respected craft that can be quite
intricate that I'm hooked that this is
what I need I mean it has been said that
you know for writers it hurts more not
to do it than to do it are you up for a
lifetime of all the range of emotions
you are going to be going through as a
writer as an artist does this what you
want to do really they want to be an
artist that's great
but understand that it is not the simple
and easy choice to make in life quite
the contrary
but it is a fabulous fabulous journey
unlike unlike any other I think